congratulations you know I've been a fan
since the days of Aqua black girl
um and I'm just wondering have you begun
to to wrap your head around the fact of
leaving
um this insecure and leaving your
character behind leaving this story
behind that we all love so much I have
I've been wrapping my head around this
since season the candidly season three
but wow so grateful to be able to play
this this character who's obviously a
version of me and in the same way that I
want this character to grow like I want
to be able to grow too so I think that's
that's what comes with it is just I've
played her for a long time and I have so
much more that I want to do but being on
set every day I'm I'm definitely taking
it in on a different level now just in
terms of wow like this is I love this
family this is my family and you know
we've done so much and these people are
incredible and I feel so blessed to work
with them and I know that I'll look back
on this time very very fondly as I do
now I'm speaking for the collective can
we get more than eight episodes please
uh we are we're getting one day episodes
Issa Ray I have a question for you now
you once famously said that you're
rooting for all black people and it's
clear that we're all rooting for you how
does it feel to have you and your work
recognized with so much love
you know what I it's it means the world
to me it's the only validation that that
matters is black people's validation so
I really appreciate NAACP for like I
said for honoring us uh it means so much
hey Isa congratulations on your win
um just tell me about how insecure has
influenced the other work that you've
done uh over the past few years and how
it will impact what you're working on
coming up
insecure has been the Gateway you know
it's apprentice and I were just talking
maybe I think it was oh two days ago
just about how we
at least I didn't imagine season one
would would lead to so many
opportunities and he kind of felt like
you know we didn't know that it would
get this far but he had an inkling
um and it's just been such a
such a
such an experience and such a launch pad
for so many of our careers in a way that
I never imagined but I'm so grateful for
what is it about 15 projects that you're
working on right now so yeah yeah I just
wanted to know what your opinion is on
what what what what is what is causing
the shift or the version you know the
just the mushrooming number of black
shoulder Runners compared to years past
I think in the abstract I always credit
the Obama era I feel like that in the
same way that Hollywood is always
influenced by the culture and and
politics in a way I think that seeing a
black man in the White House and a black
family triggered something in studio
heads where they were just like let's
let's make
more content that caters to like this is
amazing and I feel like that indirectly
translated into making sure that we had
more representation on the screen and
then of course with the success of shows
like Scandal you know it's really
blackish it just it was more of a hunger
for for our stories and it was a rare
time where Hollywood was in in step with
what the culture was what Black Culture
wanted to see what we had been demanding
for years
um and since then things have changed
but uh I think that it's just we we make
culture in so many ways and
um people are just catching up to us and
finally catching up to how good our
stories are we just wanted to sort of
get how you feel about the increase in
Black diversity in the award season with
like the hfpa not having any black
members versus like the Oscars most
diverse
um nominations in history what do you
think sort of is the next step for
awards and in general
The Next Step I mean
uh I just want the awards to feel like
the NBA Finals you know where it's like
there's no question of who's the best
there's no question of the people who
made it to the playoffs and the finals
deserve to be there nobody got paid off
nobody is you know
um
is is fluff it's just you know that
you're being honored because you've
created a great piece of work and I
don't think that's too much to ask for
so regardless of of race and whatever I
just want the awards and the people
behind the scenes
to vote based on Merit and it's kind of
hard to do that I don't think we're
there yet uh but hopefully we'll get
there one day
well I'm loving the room that you're in
between the Sesame Street sign and the
speaking notes I'm in love
um
but you are clearly where the money
resides after signing this deal with
Warner congratulations with that but
recently you shared in an interview with
Tracy Ellis Ross that you needed to step
back and act like you were going to be
here for a while and you know I was
taken back from that because I'm like of
course you are uh what a vote that
thought
I just don't want to pick anything for
granted I I just know how
just as a consumer of what Hollywood is
um as a as an avid viewer I understand
and have seen people have their time and
then people be gone and you're like what
the [ __ ]
they were a thing and
I've been a way where it's like this
could be a moment in time and that's
always been a source of anxiety in terms
of even like oh I should take on this
project or I should take on this
opportunity because I don't know how
long I'm going to be here I might not
get more opportunities and after a while
and even I was just like I need to to
stop that I mean stop acting like that
and take my time and like I had to
before and even though before I you know
broke into the industry I was really
trying to make it but it was still like
carefully crafted and very intentional
and I think it's it's a matter of
getting back to that like you know stop
being scared stop being anxious that
you're not gonna be here and just focus
on making good stuff
but you are becoming like a media Mogul
for sure and I love that you also
haven't lost your activist side what do
you think when you hear all of this High
Praise And well-deserved praise and why
do you think it's been so important to
you to lift up others in your community
and Beyond one
um I mean praise is always welcome but
I'm one of those people that can't say
compliments uh very well they make me
uncomfortable and public Praises a lot
because I'm always like the cynical side
is like okay when they gonna turn
against me because it always happens so
I welcome it and I'm so grateful for the
support that we've got and I'm so
grateful for this award and
um I just don't take anything too
seriously
what I wanted to ask you is you know
you've been making us laugh for many
many years and you're going to be
providing us with even more
entertainment with your new company
hooray which again congrats for that as
well so what I wanted to ask you what
has made you laugh and brought you Joy
in the past year especially with
everything that's been going on
man I mean outside of my friends and my
group chats
uh you know I mean I I keep crediting it
but big mouth has been a pleasant
surprise surprise and I only like kind
of learned about it and started checking
for it and I've been a fan of Nick Roll
I love him but when Quinta and um Lena
were on there I saw people tagging me
like ah this quote and I was like I
don't know they're not shooting and I
started watching the show and it's so
hilarious and then ultimately got to
their episode but it is
funny as hell and that has been a
pleasant surprise of entertainment
during this pandemic it's been a comfort
show for me
[Music]